on monogamy
I would really like to hear I would
really like to hear you talk about what
your views on monogamy are
um okay so I spoke about this a few
times and there is a social scientist by
the name of Robert P barash who wrote a
book called out of Eden and in that book
he basically he basically said that
human beings are not wired to be
monogamous
um
um he was saying that this is his his
argument that human beings are more
closer to Apes
and apes aren't monogamous like a
certain percentage of apes are not
monogamous and so when
quote unquote cheating happens it's
because of a biological and a wiring
let's say that a lot of men have and he
was also saying that
prior to Western colonization of the
world
most people whether you go to
Africa Asia Middle East were living in
some kind of pilliginous or polygamous
type situation and it's only the coming
of the western civilization where
everyone said okay one month one woman
whereas generally before that people
were living in
you know multiple type relationship
scenarios so it's like yeah when when he
put it like that I was like okay cool
because a lot of women now they wonder
why you know men are cheating men are
cheeks men are dogs blah blah and it's
like well maybe they're not wired that
way and I'm not saying that because I've
been in monogamous relationships
I'm not saying that men cannot be
monogamous yeah I'm saying that probably
a lot of them are not but what is
happening is that because
I believe women have been sold the dream
of monogamy house kids
white picket fence my husband Mike that
they've been like that dream of like
Prince Charming has been sold
in this Society a lot of people don't
understand why a lot of men are doing
like doing this kind of stuff and I'm
not making excuses for men doing it I'm
just saying a lot I think the
conversation needs to be had because I
think
um a lot of men are lying to themselves
and also lying to their women because
I'm telling you as a man men know
whether they're monogamous or not right
they know when they get into a
relationship whether they're going to
cheat on this woman or not oh you know I
mean so if they know
can a woman handle being told you know
what I do I because don't get me wrong
men love their woman they can say you
know what baby I love you I want to be
with the rest of my life but
if the rest of my life is the next 50
years do you think your vagina is the
only vagina I'm gonna see for that next
50 years
how realistic is that that's what I'm
asking like how realistic is that you
know what I mean like
of course so if you're saying that so
then what if the man were to be like you
know
able to be in like an open relationship
would it be I mean you'd have to say
like oh the woman can also do the same
as well can you
um I think so this is my personal
opinion now this is not like anything
but I think when it comes to
women and that
the
the mer the murky water on that is if
she was to get pregnant who's whose baby
would it be yeah do you know I mean like
who's whose child would it be would it
be the guy's child would it be that
guy's child would you would it would a
man just say okay cool it doesn't matter
it's from him and it's going to be all
of our childhood men ain't really built
that way I think there's a reason why
you know Lions when they take over a
pride they kill all the children of the
previous women
It's like because it's like no I want to
start my thing like I don't care about
those like they literally kill the
babies of that thing they're like I want
to start my thing and it's like men
generally are wired differently from
women I think
I just think it's different I don't know
I think it's just hard to compare animal
like mammals because like I would say
like humans were like a little more
intelligent you know yeah like
emotionally and just like common like I
don't know how to say the word like
Common Sense we have a little bit
they're more conscious they're more
conscious than animals yeah
so I wouldn't be like oh you know
because like uh of what is a family of
line kills like another person's child
then that means like oh like no but how
many of you have been cheating how many
of you been cheated on
yeah
so there's so many women out there
why
well because we like a small percentage
like if um it's like if you ask 80 of
women what they want in a man they list
20 of men sometimes even less right so
like for example only 15 ish percent of
guys are over six foot I don't know the
exact number so if you want a guy over
six five six two I'm good you're like
I'd say you add like you know money on
top of that it's like a smaller and
smaller percentage of guys and then you
know chemistry Vibes whatever it is yeah
whatever and then you realize that
you're like competing for like a very
smooth yeah and that small group of men
understand that they're being competed
for right and so their options are
boundless and it's like if you're going
for those kind of guys who have
boundless options is that
do you think they're not going to try
and take one of those options at one
point in time like do you really think
so
and I'm not saying that it's right or
wrong by the way I'm not I'm just saying
it happens I have a follow-up question
do you do you believe women are
hypergamous of course they are okay so
hypergamy it just means like I would say
the best way to describe it is we want
to get the best possible like maybe yeah
yeah we want to date up so then by that
like logic do you think if we if I have
a family and I can do better with than
my husband I should leave my husband
because by Nature I'm hypergamous I
don't think you should
um
sorry excuse me I don't think you should
leave your husband who you've made a
commitment to
just because you're hypergamous so so
then would you say the same thing for
men you shouldn't cheat on your wife
that you've made the commitment to just
because yeah yeah I would I would I
actually would I think if you make a
commitment okay you are bound by that
commitment okay I believe that however I
I think a lot of people make commitments
not being honest yeah and that's why
yeah that's true that is why the
cheating happens if a guy came to you
and be like you know what baby I love
you we've been together for this long
blah blah but you know at some point in
time I'm just I'm just gonna do
something right that's more honest but
you as a woman have to now decide
whether you're okay with that and that's
being honest what men do is like no baby
you're gonna be interested you the rest
of my life is with you and no one else
it's like stop lying
why are you lying so I think yeah if you
make a commitment and you sign a
contract you should be upheld to that
contract I think I think many people
sign that contract not known lion
and I think that's so important to like
know who you are like I think a lot of
men think oh women need to find
themselves I think that's like more like
stereotype like normally to understand
themselves know themselves but men need
to know who they are yes in order to
make such a commitment like know what
you're know who you are as a person
before you make it come like I can
commit to you but you can't because
nobody can no if he wants to he will but
like to a certain extent it's not in
their character like no but women think
that a man committing or not committing
is having sex and they are like you can
still be like a man that's okay from
monogamous relationship but maybe or not
maybe you prefer polyamorous
relationships and maybe you just don't
understand that but you're committing to
that knowing you're still going to be
right in your thing right but if you
actually understood yourself studied
yourself you actually put in the time
and levels of commitment to being like
you know what this is who I am and then
knowing what you can give to a woman
that's a different thing but to know to
not actually fully put in that work and
then be like you know what baby I can
commit to you like no you can't like